casi un mes después de que salvador
ramos de 18 años matara a tiros a 19
niños en oval de texas y más de 5
semanas después de que otro joven de 18
años matara a 10 personas afroamericanas
en un supermercado en búfalo nueva york
un grupo de demócratas y republicanos
presentó un proyecto de ley que según el
demócrata chris murphy salvaría miles de
vidas
believe the sweet we wow creo que esta
semana aprobaremos una ley que se
convertirá en la pieza más importante de
la legislación contra la violencia
armada que el congreso haya aprobado en
30 años se trata de un gran avance y lo
que es importante es un avance
bipartidista
el proyecto de ley reforzará los
controles de antecedentes y las
sanciones a los traficantes de armas
también permite a las autoridades
bloquear la compra de armas y confiscar
las en algunos casos específicos también
proporciona fondos para la salud mental
los tejanos están disgustados e
indignados por lo ocurrido en la escuela
primaria rob me complace informar de que
como el duro trabajo de varios senadores
de esta cámara hemos hecho algunos
progresos importantes
sin embargo el proyecto de ley está muy
lejos de las demandas clave planteadas
por los demócratas incluido el
presidente de eeuu joe biden no impone
una prohibición general de las armas de
asalto automáticas o al menos eleva el
límite de edad para su compra de 18 a 21
años michel mccaul líder republicano del
senado ha descrito la nueva legislación
como un paquete de sentido común pero el
poderoso grupo de presión de la
asociación nacional del rifle arremetió
contra el nuevo proyecto de ley diciendo
que podría ser abuso para restringir la
compra legal de armas el proyecto de ley
podría ser aprobado al final de la
semana necesitará el voto de al menos 10
republicanos y de los 50 demócratas